welcome to this video playing camera
Ciro from Spain let's stay with what I
know clay the Rhodope has the Spanish is
black yeah I get the she goin probably
yep yeah this is also a line this is the
traditional way to play that has
officiated back in the 60s trying to
remember our displayed think was c4
somehow but yeah this is this is not a
bad line for white absolutely not i'm
but i haven't studied this for ages I I
had games where light d for when what I
went with 94 this funky piece sacrifice
can I do that here hey I always I always
feel tempted let's do it k mmm takes
I probably have to take with the bishop
and then play d3m I still feel this is
an interesting sacrifice maybe it's not
one hundred percent correct but it's it
feels interesting
looks like d2 is coming and I know
getting getting the pawn back so I can
just take the rook now complete rook
okay you can take a sick sighs okay I
mean I must take the rope here no one no
argue about that okay if I take here
night watch my Chi form probably
it's not playing with the rook on a one
and the bishop on d 1 so this is
somewhat hard to believe that this
really should be a should be great but
still I am I have some material already
i need to consider if there is some
sense I'm just returning stuff ok let's
take here 94 probably but I thought that
rock d6 should be pretty ok returning
the exchange
I don't know if I can do without it and
I cannot think five minutes see awesome
like need to be quick now maybe you can
consider something like Queen g3 check
ok ok I wanted to return the exchange
wait ok let's return it and how how to
play it now screen g5 all the time and
g6
my points are also dangerous but okay
that's that super difficult me with this
long time my king is of course open I
want to play Queen e5 him I thought this
should be good for me actually because I
i get the pawn now or get queens of all
get the porn queen air force piqua be 4i
bishop before our rookie six maybe
lookie success maybe even better
I will get six Quincy form mmm this I
didn't seem time morning ok
can I go quindi six at the end my pants
probably not
what a game this was never ever correct
right absolutely never but it was
difficult at least I thought check check
check check mate yeah whatever I have
told that totally spot this is nonsense
I mean here this is this is completely
incorrect but I didn't refute it simple
as that ok Bishop takes and now let's
see you know I probably other computers
just does not want to return the
material just place quindi 6-3 yeah as a
human you what you tend to be afraid
yeah but it's just better I mean if you
look at it a bit you yeah it's pretty
evident that this is better check you
must go to j away doesn't really want
and here there's no threat whatsoever
yeah that's minus 3.5 according to the
engine and there's really no not it's
not even in Hannah tech here he's got
those two video tech pieces on d 1 and a
1 okay oh this is also wins but it gets
it gets tricky and this is suggestive
mistaken Queen d8 immediately out of
course preventing Queen g5 I just need
to get get my piece assorted a bit then
i'll be winning with this pawn chain
it's pretty clear just need to not get
mated or blunder stuff then then those
pawns are immensely strong now something
like let's say gives a check and place
place
this for example I just centralized and
this is this is simply simply too strong
I can also get the bishop back here it's
a fantastic position for black minus 2.5
if you believe the engine and yeah here
I'm starting to to drift f6 it's the
calm suggestion with the edge that looks
fishy lips oh let's say hard for a human
but here what I did overlook is I
overlooked I overlooked this move with
them e1a checked f7 a tech King h8 as a
cold-blooded defense but I didn't see
that until I'm I'm probably just losing
well just 0.7 provide us to go here yeah
it's tough to analyze I've got 30
seconds and they have spoiled it before
I mean the whole game should should be
over long ago so on that's not really it
doesn't really matter that much just
just 26 what would have one relatively
easily yeah okay thanks for watching